[Music]
Wow
hey old-timer forget something
frankerz aren't we
white this cutting Oh No
what's the matter build that someone
dull the paper cutter hey grandma it's
me Ricky
yeah I'm selling magazines for school
again so I mean a little bit of money
yeah
now Oh real quick I'm gonna need the
expiration date and the three-digit
quote on the back that is very good
Doris you pass your Alzheimer's test oh
thank you very much
Oh everything there's something about
ink energy
it's weird how unembarrassed I am my BOB
[Music]
no more pranks okay we're not in college
anymore
we're grownups so act like it hell is
this what do you mean it's a coffee pot
is that not coffee in that dr. pepper
[Music]